you might not think that a movie about a
magical martial arts tournament would be
all that complicated but 2021's mortal
kombat is packed to the brim with
references to the game's decades-long
war we're here to break down the hidden
meaning of the characters in mortal
kombat
a lot of the characters we're talking
about here are dead by the end of the
movie however that doesn't mean they
won't pop up in a sequel
in the games characters come back from
death all the time and a shang tsung
says
death is only another portal indeed
mortal kombat makes the fickle nature of
death explicitly clear when feudal
japanese ninja hanzo hisashi murdered by
rival b
han in the opening scene returns in the
climax as the undead warrior known as
scorpion
scorpion's backstory in the movie is
almost exactly the same as it is in the
games
references to the feuding ninja clans of
the shirai ryu and the lin kuei suggest
the films could be interested in
exploring this aspect of the games in
more detail
if so this opens up a long list of
future characters to potentially include
this is all subject to change of course
given the centering of scorpion's
descendant and the film's protagonist
cole young
and of course scorpion himself is still
wandering the land of the living there
are any number of directions he could go
based on a story in the games
bihan has his own mortal kombat code
name as fans know well
sub zero however this is somewhat
misleading while a character named
sub-zero appears in every mortal kombat
game there's only one game in which that
character has actually been behind
in fact bihan hasn't been sub-zero since
the very first mortal kombat
he's killed by scorpion immediately
afterward and the mantle of sub-zero is
taken up by his more heroic younger
brother
quail yang in mortal kombat 2. so while
the film's sub-zero is the original
version of the character he's
technically not the version we've been
using to frustrate our friends since
1993.
as he does in the games scorpion kills
sub-zero at the end of the new movie
but joe taslim the actor who plays bihan
is reportedly signed on for four more
films
between that and the fact that his body
is collected by shang tsung's mysterious
teleporting smoke before the credits
roll he's guaranteed to be back for
sequel
moreover while he's only sub-zero in the
first installment bihan is hardly absent
from the remainder of the video game
series
in 2004's mortal kombat deception it's
revealed that the sinister undead wraith
known as noob saibot who debuted in
mortal kombat 2
is actually the resurrected spirit of
bihan mortal kombat screenwriter greg
russo has already acknowledged that
bihan's transformation into noob saibots
is part of his plan for the character
we'll see if he keeps the admittedly
stupid name
considering goro status is one of the
strongest and most popular mortal kombat
characters it's somewhat surprising to
see the four armed warrior prince show
up just long enough to be defeated and
killed by coal
given the enigmatic black smoke that
claims his body however he'll likely be
back in some capacity as mortal kombat
fans know gorel's character offers the
filmmakers many options going forward
if they want to spend more time in
outworld the realm the movies villains
call home
goro could be an entry point for that
viewers could also potentially learn
more about the shokon race and even
about their rival species the
scorpion-like centaurians
most tantalizingly goro eventually joins
the side of the heroes in the video
games
but let's be honest assuming these
movies eventually get to the actual
mortal kombat tournament it would make
the most
sense for a returning goro to reprise
his iconic role as the undefeated
champion of mortal kombat
molina is the most notable soon minion
who doesn't get expressly set up for
future sequels via black smoke of
destiny one of the franchise's most
popular characters she does
get more screen time than goro but still
ends up with a gigantic hole through her
torso by the film's conclusion
it would be surprising if molina didn't
make it into the sequels in some form
and her video game origin as a hybrid
clone lends itself well to an
explanation for her return
but even if melina doesn't return her
presence in the film still carries a
whole lot of weight
when molina first appeared in the mortal
kombat trailer some fans expressed
consternation at what seemed to be the
relative normalcy of her face
by the end of the film those fans were
likely pacified since she does
eventually break out the monstrous
sharp-toothed grin she's known for
this act of fan service could also be an
indicator that the tarkattan race will
appear in future installments
most likely in the form of baraka whose
massive teeth and wrist blades have been
part of the franchise since mortal
kombat 2.
of course the other half of molina's
genes come from her twin sister kitana a
major heroic character curiously absent
from the new movie should katana appear
in a sequel she might introduce her home
realm medina into the film's mythology
somewhat early in the film shang tsung
sends somebody called saizoth to attack
earth's heroes
this character turns out to be a
fiendish reptilian creature boasting
wicked claws and the power to turn
invisible
in the game saizoth is actually known as
reptile and is the first secret
character in fighting game history
though it was originally just a green
version of the scorpion sub-zero
character template he eventually gained
actual reptilian form and a backstory to
boot
he's the last surviving member of the
soren species who all have the ability
to turn invisible or take human form
natara is another minor character who
pops up in mortal kombat
representing one of outworld's alien
species she only shows up for a couple
of minutes
and it's unclear how much of her video
game origin we're meant to infer
in the game she's a vampire that is to
say a member of a vampiric alien species
that needs blood to survive
she and reptile also have a history
together in the games since natara gets
eviscerated by kung lao in the movie and
reptile gets his heart ripped out and
film based future isn't looking good
still it's possible that their
respective species will play some role
in the franchise down the line
goro and molina are two of the most
notable mortal kombat characters
reptile has a cult following and even
natara has the benefit to being a
traditional vampire
but only the most die-hard mortal combat
junkies remember reiko who was created
as a thinly re-skinned noob cybot
replacement for mortal kombat 4 and has
barely appeared in the game since
even if the movie just needed a
low-level side character who could be
killed off by a jax briggs's fatality
and never seen again
the inclusion of reiko is a strange
choice fans can't help but wonder if
reiko is meant to foreshadow the arrival
of central mortal kombat villain xiao
khan
the emperor of outworld the last of
shang tsung's minions cabal gets a
character makeover in the movie he still
sports his trademark hook swords mask
and respirators
and is still an ex-member of the black
dragon mercenary organization
but he's also unambiguously villainous
as opposed to the reformed criminal he
is in the games
he's more well known than characters
like reiko and natara but still obscure
enough that he's probably dead
for good however his presence in the
film as well as his interactions with
the black dragon leader kano suggests
that the mortal kombat movies might
bring in some other black dragon related
plot elements and characters
plenty of minor characters from the
games have been a part of the black
dragon
which at one point in the game was under
cabal's leadership this being mortal
kombat the black dragon naturally has an
opposite
the red dragon its rival and parent
organization a full-fledged crime
syndicate whose inclusion in the films
could provide an entry point for more on
the sequels
the red dragon is also a gateway to some
of the larger scale lore of the mortal
kombat series
if you're going to talk about the
mythology of mortal kombat you have to
talk about the lightning god in the room
raiden was always going to be part of
any mortal kombat movie but the fact
that he's alive and in charge by the end
of this one suggests he will continue to
be a major part to the next one as well
there's a deep well of lore to be drawn
from when it comes to raiden the film
stays pretty vague about what exactly is
going on at the highest levels of this
universe but the phrase elder gods is
mentioned and it's significant
raiden himself moonlights as an elder
god joining and leaving the ranks
throughout the series
more importantly any potential interest
the filmmakers may have in the elder
gods will lead them to another major
mortal combat villain the fallen elder
god shinnok
in fact shinnok's signature amulet of
power can be seen in raiden's temple in
the movie suggesting that
as in the games raiden defeated him
centuries ago though the threat of a
revived shinnok is always in play
if there's one thing about the movie
most mortal kombat fans probably agree
on is that josh lawson's kano is
absolutely one of the best things about
it
while the leader of the black dragons
mercenaries is oddly placed on the side
of the heroes throughout the first part
of the film he turns on them halfway
through
lawson is a delight every time he's on
screen which makes it a bit of a bummer
that sonja kills him with a lawn gnome
prior to the end of the movie
however there's reason to think this
isn't the end for kano for one thing it
would seem counterproductive to just cut
bait on lawson after he stole the show
so completely for another there's the
matter of his face
scarred in his fight against reptile in
the games kano is cybernetically
enhanced bearing a metal faceplate
pretty much exactly where reptile's
claws raked him
that's also the same eye sonja drove the
gnome through an eye that
in the games is cybernetic and shoots
lasers bringing kano back as a cyborg
would align with his video game origins
provide a new source for his eye beam
and most importantly keep lawson in the
franchise
no matter how many of my people we put
in the ground
there's a reason that the film's
insertion of cole young an original
character not present in the video games
has caused so much bafflement among fans
of the franchise
mortal kombat already has a main
character lou kang
originally conceived as shaolin mung can
be considered the primary hero of the
entire series and most adaptations place
him in that role
robin chow plays him in the 290s movies
and there's never any question about who
the protagonist of those films is
it's decidedly odd to see another
character in liu kang's place
and especially strange to see luke kang
show up in the movie anyway in a
secondary role
unlike his mentor kung lao lu kang makes
it to the end of the film
it's possible that he will ascend to
main character status at some point in
the future
perhaps the filmmakers decided to
include luke kang as a sort of fail-safe
if the audience reaction to coal is less
than positive
but even if that never happens lou was
already dropping hints about other
portions of the mortal kombat universe
he could unlock
such as his name dropping in beaurey cho
master of the drunken fist
technically johnny cage doesn't appear
in the new mortal kombat movie however
there's a direct reference to cage in
the movie's final shot as the camera
lingers on a poster for a fictional film
entitled citizen cage starring johnny
himself
this comes directly after the victorious
heroes agree they need to find more
fighters before their next battle
and after cole informs us that he's
headed to hollywood to track one such
fighter down
it's the movie's only direct suggestion
of a sequel teasing us with the
potential arrival of one of the
franchise's biggest names
one of the original mortal kombat
characters cage is an iconic part of the
series
a cocky martial artist and actor he
enters the tournament to prove he does
his own stunts he's also famous for
being sonia blade's love interest
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite action movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one